[inaudible]
THE GOOD MORNING WE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN OUR HEARING
TODAY YOU'LL SEE WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM --
MISTER COOLEY WOULD YOU THAT WE
WOULD YOU LIKE CENTER BUILT TWO
WITNESSES PER SIDE THREE PLANETS
EACH.
THERE'S ANY TRAINERS AND I
WHATEVER OUT THERE SO --
YOU KNOW PLEASE BE BRIEF MR
COOLEY.
THIS BILL AS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE AUTHORIZES SPECIALIZED
HEALTH PLAN.
IN SPECIFICALLY VS P. TO USE A
STATISTICAL DATA SERVICES. TO
IDENTIFY SUSPECTED FRAUD AND TO
KERN RIVER DOWN.
SO IT SUPPORTS INTEGRITY AND
DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE.
EUGENE UP TO DATE --
METHODOLOGIES ARE COURSE AND I
VOTE.
OF THE SENATE BILL CEMENT IN THE
SET.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
THAT YOU'RE WHATEVER STUFF
THAT'S A REPRESENTED VSP VISION
CARE THAT SPONSORED THE MEASURE.
HAS ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HAS
POINTED OUT THE BILL PROVIDES
THE REQUISITE STATUTORY PLATFORM
FOR US TO CONTINUE.
OUR COMPUTER ASSISTED ANTI FRAUD
PROGRAM WHICH IS REQUIRED UNDER
THE NOTS CAN ACT.
ITS COLLABORATION OF THE WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE NO OPPOSITION
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK PER NIGHT.
THANKS VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TIMES MAKE
VERY MUCH AS SOON AS WE HAVE
BEFORE WE WILL APPEAL TO HAVE A
MOTION AND TAKE A PICK UP VIA
THE ITEM.
PER GOOD I'M GONNA STEP GOT TORN
ASSIST THEM LIKE I CAN GET IN
THERE COR THAT'S GOOD THANK YOU
SIR.
THING PROMESAS.
MR ROBERT MEMBERS OF HEALTH
COMMITTEE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
THEM COME DOWN.
OR OVER OR UP.
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE
[inaudible]
YEAH GATHERING ACCORDING TO THE
RIVER.
YOU SEE --
MOMENT GOSH YOU'D BETTER CHECK
UP ON THE HOLD IT RIGHT THERE
ARE PROBLEMS THAT LIVE.
IN IT.
THEY ALL OF A
TRAIN ARRIVED YOU
GUYS ALL GOT HERE IS LIKE WHAT
THE HECK.
WITH WITH WHICH WHICH TRAIN WAS
THAT.
I KNOW I KNOW I KNOW.
CAME MEN SECRETARY WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
WE NEED TO CALL THE ROLL.
WELL HERE THIRD WOULD CARE MASER
[inaudible]
AGAR CURRY [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
RODRIGUEZ HERE SANTIAGO.
THURMOND [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND BY A CHORUS OF PEOPLE BUT
I THINK IT WAS MR HIS AREA --
SO MADAMS THAT MEN SECRETARY IT
PLEASE THEY MOTION IS I DO
CONCUR IN SENATE AMENDMENTS
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE EGGER CURRY.
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BIRD I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE LOW
MOAN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
I I NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN
[inaudible]
BERMAN I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT WE HAVE THIRTEEN ZERO THE
MOTION PASSES --
WE WILL.
ACTUALLY --
AND THE INTEREST OF EVERYBODY'S
SCHEDULE WILL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE
THE ROLE AND AND THEM AND AND
CLOSE THE MEETING THANK YOU.
JUST GET YOUR COPY [inaudible]
THIS.
WHAT? THIRTY FINALLY.
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR GREAT
THOSE I DON'T SOMETHING HELP
SOMEBODY ELSE.
BUT I THINK.
I HOPE CREEK.
I DON'T YOU KNO